mais avant les gagnants du coc u19 il y
en a et dans la catégorie fabricants
pharmaceutiques
j'ai nommé récit pharma mon après le oui
de l'europe au vaccin moderna le
sous-traitant va accélérer la production
une opportunité pour la ville
explications avec samuel colin sur place
les 250 salariés sont déjà à pied
d'oeuvre
la production de ce vaccin est considéré
comme un challenge pour eux alors qu'ils
fabriquent habituellement des solutions
anesthésiante pour ce délégué syndical
le rythme de travail va s'intensifier
mais toujours en trois-huit en
production en journée dans l'est dans
les laboratoires mais on risque
dès que l'on vend la incessamment sous
peu
déjà de travailler les week-ends pour
être du 24 sur 24 7 jours sur 7 c'est un
changement profond de nos conditions de
travail
et justement les accords d'entreprise
sur le travail signé en 1996 sont remis
à plat par la direction début décembre
quelques jours avant l'annoncé du
contrat de modern a et du recrutement de
25 % de personnel en plus dans la ville
les habitants rencontrés se réjouissent
de ce vaccin fabriqué chez eux
le fait que ça soit fait en touraine ça
peut être qu'une bonne chose parce que
ça va emmener des emplois ben j'en suis
les gens sur eux-mêmes même fier limite
des fiertés oui oui oui parce que s'il
ya une réussite on se dit que va-t-on
que pour les personnes qui en ont besoin
le maire lui espère des emplois et
notamment attiré des commerçants il y en
a une trentaine dans cette ville de 8000
habitants une commune déjà connu pour
son site du cea très protégé peut-être
une raison plus de choisir mon pour le
laboratoire américain
la surveillance de l'entreprise récifs
arme sera dans tous les cas renforcé
nous allons être aidés par les la
gendarmerie de loches et de mon voisin
est effectivement le fait qu'elles
soient proches du sauvage renforce
également l'aspect sécuritaire puisque
nous sommes dans une zone qui est
protégé au niveau au niveau de l'armée
l'édile aimerait maintenant voir les
vaccins distribués aux habitants
rapidement dans un courrier à la préfète
il lui propose de mettre à disposition
l'espace jean cocteau de sa ville comme
vaccinodromes